glaube ich stärke 3 meteorit der schutz
einfach direkt vor mir ab alter chalki
wir wären fast gestorben was sagst du
dazu
braun braun steht für mich mal für mich
o peaches am still
hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer breit in folge wäre total
sprachfehler war zu einer weiteren folge
minecraft hero auf dem an minecraft
hexel auf dem hero server mit dabei sind
ankomme
drei verschiedene städte drei
verschiedene städte ok chillig jetzt
krieg ich glaube wir pennen bei gut ist
eigentlich egal ob die perlen können
oder nicht weil ich wollte mich um eine
trial rüstung kümmern
übrigens meine lieben freunde wenn ihr
dieses video seht ist ja gerade der
also das video kommt am 21 11 raus und
ich ab 20ten helfen wo ich gerade
aufnehme führerschein praxisprüfung
bestand ich habe den führerschein und ja
ich bin noch 17 also ich mache dieses
begleitende fahren bisschen jetzt ein
paar monate
ich wollte dass ein ganzes jahr machen
weil ich fanden das war unnötig und ich
hatte gerade als alle anderen
führerschein gemacht haben war halt bei
mir so ich habe viele freunde von
anderen schulen und die waren halt so
alle ich hatte halt klausur und dann
habe ich sie immer vor mir hergeschoben
und dies dass iris fischer hält und ich
bin noch nie so richtig dazu gekommen
den führerschein zu machen jetzt habe
ich den jetzt gemacht und mit ein
bisschen verspätung aber egal meine
eltern mit behinderten eltern sind auf
jeden fall stolz auf mich jetzt kann ich
noch ein bisschen da ist ein bisschen
begleitet immer diese blöde meteoriten
er bringt nix diese scheiß herumschweben
der items so mega unnötig jedenfalls
dachte mein handy dreht man hinnehmen
dass immer um wäre übrigens wert die
coolste hülle
das ist eine lego belkin hunde da seht
ihr kind an alle die die cap auf wollen
ich sag euch nicht von welchem team das
ist unnötig finde wenn man sich eine
kerb holt da bin ich weiß in welchem
team das ist sondern sich die verfolger
liegen dicaprio sieht es ist leder
wartet danach rede ich weiter wenn ich
danach noch mal ein bisschen auf suche
gehen
ich weiß ich habe in der letzten folge
bauer übersehen so eine sekunde nachdem
ich gesagt habe
schreibt mir die kommentare wenn ich das
übersehe
und ich einfach nur nein ich hab's halt
wirklich übersehen das war halt ein
bisschen so ich habe schon drei teile
von dieser rüstung nur noch die schuhe
oder eine spinne
doch die will ein bisschen stress
schiebt ein bisschen stress besser zu
machen im tokioter wir kommen einfach
laufen
es ist und chillig wir nehmen einfach
desktop so eine blöde spinne und wir
machen hier einfach mit einem schlag den
moneten die einfach mit unserem coolen
schwert hier was ich von kabul nicht
essen was ich von kef habe und dann auch
noch verzaubert übrigens danke an ich
lese ja fleißig kommentare deswegen rede
ich auch immer so viel weil ich dann
immer noch auf die kommentare eingehen
ein eingehen ich gehe auf die komplette
ich gehe auf die kommentare ein
schreiben ja immer so viele leute damit
kannst du deinen job promoter fliegen
danke jungs ich weiß deswegen ich habs
nur die letzten folgen aber mal ein
bisschen vergessen dass uns da oben was
im punkt keine ahnung und einfach kopf
abgehackt kopf bruder bruder dem kopf
oder dem kopf hoch nix passiert ja alles
gut
okay aber wirst ja gesagt fällt auf
jeden fall immer nach pflanze ich bin ja
der typ der sich um dinge kümmern muss
um essen und so das werden wir natürlich
auch bald machen
wie gesagt möchte ich erstmal mich
kümmern dass ich eine vernünftige
rüstung habe und der ganzen schweiz
darum und danach werde ich mich um meine
aufgabe hier kümmern als könig die
anderen ignorieren mich irgendwie die
schreiben gar nicht alter auf amazon.de
ihr clip auf einmal die crossair geht
nicht auf mich an aber er schreibt
einfach aber ich glaube jeder von uns
sind gerade getrennt voneinander auf
wenn es anders machen würde dann wird
das glaube ich nur sagen nicht so in
chats schreiben na gut egal wer in
stockum diesem filter werden richtig
viele weiß mittlerweile wenn wir immer
goldene haben wieder das wird eine
goldene haben da schon schwarzes amber
um mein gott geil bombardements recht
stark ich werde irgendwann so ein
riesiges feld in bauen mit essen und
trinken trinken
vor allem das land aus und wer wollt ihr
eigentlich das trikot von brocken hat
einfach ein eigenes häuschen
so bekommt jetzt noch hier ein bisschen
was wir müssen noch auf die suche nach
hacks ik lizenzen gehen sagte der
spieler vor leben live jahr
nicht mehr natürlich ist bisschen doof
dass wir jetzt weihnachten vielleicht
losziehen
aber egal so leute erstmal folgender
plan ich möchte mir eine brüstung
komplett machen triebe rüstung komplett
heißt wenn die komplette ist habe ich
glaube ich stärke 3
metroid der schutz einfach direkt vor
mir ab alter chalki wir wären fast
gestorben was sagst du dazu
diego vor
mein gott jokus kathrin naja das ist als
die erste dazu sagen kann
mein gott wie ja ein bisschen angst okay
die man strukturen zurück jetzt hier ein
bisschen neun stück noch ein stück ach
was fressen al attasi okay zwei dubstep
trieb auf einmal auch gut 2 des deb
keeper und so eine sternschnuppe eine
stelle stoppen
das gericht heftig gefallen ich war
eigentlich ein bisschen was suchen die
da jetzt bekommen us-star ps nur von
wissen etwas finde ich meteorit direkt
vor mir ab ich hab sie bei manchen
anderen leuten in den aufnahmen gesehen
dass da einfach so ein meteorit kam bei
mir kommt er einfach bewusster
bei mir kommt dieser fakten bei mir
kommt dieser verschlissene meteorit
einfach da kommt nichts raus glaube ich
muss das kühl neben die oder ich werde
diese scheiß erfahrung hätten rumgammeln
kühlen typen die mit ihrer erfahrung ist
es viel mehr so viele level meteorit
bringt mir ja ich hoffe da kommt jetzt
keinen dubstep repair aus borken der
meteorit bringt mir ja dieses zeugs
voraus ich mir die magnet teile
dingsbums da gemacht habe oder star dena
meinte was ja angeblich so gut sei was
ich allerdings nicht so toll finde ich
jetzt einfach mal ein bisschen vom mit
ich war ja eigentlich auf der iaa wird
gras blogspot ich habe direkt als wetter
dann darfst app creeper aber nein ich
glaube die spawn ich glaube dass der
primas von bei mir gar nicht wir haben
einfach angst vor mir seitdem ich jetzt
dieses eine intro da gemacht habe haben
die einfach mega tschüss ich glaube die
haben einfach mega chefs von mir
mittlerweile das doch so langsam so
alles bisschen ab dass gute leute ich
glaube wirklich diese dubstep krieger
die haben mittlerweile einfach die
nötigen respekt für mich weil ich habe
ja auch zwei hintereinander getötet ich
glaube einfach die trauen sich
mittlerweile auch gar nicht mehr zu
sparen bei mir in der nähe
ich war nur noch ein okay dann noch ein
wenn man kann ja eigentlich nie genug
kriegen vor dem ganzen zeugs kisten
körperlich waren wird das jetzt auf
jeden fall meteorit abgestürzt egal wie
ich die folge dann enden soll
also viel erlebt schon hier und da sogar
mal bei acht minuten
übrigens leute heute abend live stream
jahr wollte überhaupt live stream
schreibt eure kommentare ob ja jahr für
live stream an ein wenn nicht also ich
werde wahrscheinlich nachher nochmal bei
minecraft facts fragen ob er ein wollt
oder nicht nur einfach weil viele leute
gucken sich ja hier nicht hero an
sondern dann mehr so minecraft wechsel
sieht man ja auch leben verloren
viele leute schreiben wir das ja dass
die tiere einfach total uninteressant
finden und dann einfach sich bei mir und
so erst anschauen wie minecraft xvi
deswegen werde ich dann einfach da noch
mal fragen ob ihr in bayern kräftig ob
wir da land auch in leistung haben wollt
also wollten oder nicht schreibt man ja
oder nein kommentare wofür welche
antwortmöglichkeit steht sollte euch
eigentlich bewusst sein
ich muss jetzt irgendwie als ob die hoch
kommst du jockey rasiert alter der kommt
einfach
wir zählen jetzt mal ein wenig daten
sind übrigens auch gewandten
kurz ruhig bleiben käme eben die
diamanten sagte weiter laufen dort
jockey hier um hierdurch und ab ins
wasser das zum thema ab ins wasser ein
bisschen
mcnabb gucken wo sind denn hier hektik
kein knochen mexiko um mein gott das ist
ein zeichen ich muss mir diese hunde
holen
ich glaube ich jetzt wirklich mein leben
daran wie ihm die knochen zu holen
aber woher kriegt er jetzt knochen
verdammt würde es gibt hunde die
strahler mehr sondern eher wie sand am
meer
deswegen wir holen jetzt einfach jemand
anders dann hund beziehung werde wieder
die ganze familie browser pietsch
browser junior whiskys läuft freunde
einfach einfach fan einfach machen jungs
und ich höre skelette ich höre skelette
spürte gleich noch eine spinne vergiftet
sich auf jeden fall richtig gut
da ist dann sind die x knochen dritten
vista leder world jedoch komplett voll
war bis jetzt hier sollten unnötige
sachen rein dass es unnötig ach ich hab
ja auch noch ein weg nutzt ja gar nicht
hier ist ja egal ich am start stehe dann
nehme ich mit und die seite ist
eventuell auch noch nachher ganz gut war
ich höre schon wieder so komische mops
diejenigen die runter plätschern
aber mein gott das ist jetzt ein
bisschen heftig regal jungs haben
einfach noch viel leben fasst das ist
echt schillig alter wenig sache hier
einfach so wir machen schilliger
aufnahme so ein bisschen jahr und bei
uns läuft einfach ich habe sieben
knochen alter wir können uns eigentlich
heute schon noch und links holen
wie heißt der fritzl
wir können uns heute schon noch holen
der stress mein körper okay jetzt machen
wir eine andere taktik
doch nicht ich hasse es wenn spinnen
über einen sind wenn kleinere tiere
überall sind das ist so schrecklich ich
krieg das gar nicht kommen darauf gar
nicht klar wenn kleinere tiere über
schmerz agent menge spitze weg in
kleinere tiere über mir sind ja ich
komme damit gar nicht klar vor allem
wenn's irgendwie spinnen sind oder so
dann aber woher kommen die jetzt
eigentlich auf einmal alle so schnell
nach gucke ich immer etwas und das das
dass das hier noch ein paar die sachen
das war immer wieder ein schuss in den
ofen
looki looki looki alter mensch op
verlauf alexy kahles enzen kiesbett wir
dürfen zucchini verlieren so leute wir
holen uns jetzt einen neuen hund und
zwar wird das hier pietsch wenn sie will
weil pietsch ist braun braun steht für
mich
o peaches am still look speech bis zu
den heim
ich schwöre bei gott sogar das tut mir
leid komm du kriegst du direkt nein
läuft nicht weg
kriegst du direkt ein steak okay gut so
du kommst mit kaka alter wie kriegt ihr
jetzt zurück ohne dass die irgendwie
verrecken hatten wir schon mal das
problem war da das browserbasierte
darüber werden elf weg von mir ja
browser ist am start so bei der beiden
hunde sind auf jeden fall am start
ich muss jetzt eben wie zurückkommen
also ich habe so viel geschafft ich habe
die runde geholt ihr auch ich bin mit
jockey wieder ein bisschen gereizt habt
ein bisschen fraser verfahren hier
manchmal adac anrufen übrig was ich auch
arbeit machen wollte sind so war die
solche länder auf ein schiff ich wollte
auto blogs machen
ich fahre auto und macht dabei in block
die kommen jetzt endlich von hier nach
hause ohne dass sich eventuell dann
jetzt durch das ganze mehr muss der
berge hoch also wenn die hunde porten
sicher oder ja da positionen nur halt
durch es mehr als dann immer so ein
bisschen kritisch ich versuche es
einfach mal den größten um legale wege
zu gehen
hallo erstmal hier fest auf jeden fall
auch schillig wenn man dann einfach mal
so feststeckt ich gehe es den umweg
alaba der den kommt einfach so er kommt
einfach jetzt hier suchen
ich muss immer auf die uhr gucken wir
sind ja gerade mal 14 minuten auf dem
server was eigentlich relativ wenig
jetzt allerdings für die ganzen rückweg
brauchen wir noch ein bisschen zeit
also ich hoffe mal dass ich das
irgendwie
aber da hinten ist das rot und wenn ich
bei dem roten angekommen bin ich ja gar
nicht mehr so weit bis nach hause
das heißt ich sollte theoretisch am
strand her kommen lässt sich halt die
leute bei mir hier hinter mir hier
pietsch und bowser portativ runter ja
dass die hat sich hinter mir porten
können sie das geld alle nach hause
kommen es wäre natürlich schön wenn ihr
jetzt im roten dann können auf jeden
fall locker buchstäblich durch ja du
hast noch 32 leben stelle ich jetzt
nichts anja diese noch hinter uns welche
hunde bis zu mir nach hause kriegen wäre
es auf jeden fall megageil ich glaube
ich bin auch schon direkt auf dem
richtigen weg hier schon kurios kreisen
dass dieser komischen turm an den info
hervor
vorher hat daran hergekommen bin
nein das da oben ist keine existenz jahr
ein bisschen differenzieren bin ich hier
ist viel blau
ihr könnt eventuell gibt auch mit sieht
man auf jeden fall gut nähe ist nicht
neu ist alex habe ich mich hier wieder
verfahren nicht nur hier um hier um hier
um larum löffelstiel über das nicht
könne gar nicht viel
hier ist auch nichts mehr hier ist ihm
wie alles so mega verteilte man brunnen
jahrhundert noch internet ist gut hier
wurde auf jeden fall schon etwas gemacht
die stadt müsste irgendwie links von uns
liegen irgendwo über das meer
es kann nicht sein dass mehr muss doch
mal irgendwann zu ende sein ich muss
doch irgendwie rum kommen ohne dass
dadurch dass mehr weil die hunde er
trägt natürlich im meer
ich kann natürlich sitzt machen bei fiat
nehme ich dann irgendwie überholen soll
aber ich glaube so geht das heute
schaffen dies darüber
okay das cool wie jetzt die eigentlich
alles noch fit bei dir so jetzt schaffen
sie es hierüber ja okay ich habe
vertrauen in die ich glaube die schaffen
wir auch diesen weg gehe oder diesen
sogar vor mir da das gut
toki bist du betrunken wie wie läuft der
jeder bitte leute ich würde echt
wir trinken hier die ertrinken
wie soll ich denn hier nach hause kommen
mein zuhause ist da das weiß ich ganz
genau aber ich weiß nicht wie ich da
hinkommen soll wenn meine hunde daher
ertrinken
wie soll ich meine hunde nach hause
kriegen
ich mache jetzt erstmal hier dass die
hier sitzt machen hd ist halt kein bild
mit witz unter ja
options ja gut ich mir da schon
irgendwie merken muss jetzt mal ganz
kurz die durch den gucken ob ich da
wirklich ohne weil ich muss auf die
schiene die aufnahme stoppen aber ich
bin schon zwei über 20 minuten aber ich
war am anfang die ersten 20 sekunden
oder so weil ich ja nicht auf dem server
c ich checke jetzt mal ganz kurz nur auf
papier überhaupt mein zuhause ist
wo könnte das denn sonst habe ich mich
komplett verlaufen was das da unten
links überhaupt kein bock jetzt
nachzugucken ja aber da geht es doch
nicht
heute wo bin ich jetzt nicht da
wo muss ich hin ich war auf der minimap
gucken wir hier ganz schön überrascht
hier europäischen lang gelaufen
krems wo ich lange laufen obwohl ich
dann muss man erhöhe das komische burg
ich kenne sie jetzt zurück zu meinem
fischen würfel zum etlichen kunden die
irre so wie ich ihn gelaufen war ich so
weit weg ich weiß gar nicht mehr die
koordinaten so richtig schreibt mir doch
mal einfach in die koordinaten in die
koordinaten denen die kommentare
schreiben einfach in die kommentare die
koordinaten eventuell wo ich eventuell
in müsste weil ich muss auch mal lange
damit die aufnahme pausieren will ich
will jetzt wenigsten doch zurück zu
meinen hunden und die letztlich alleine
lassen
denke mal dass la wird verständnis für
gezeigt hatte
und dann gehe ich auch ganz schnell
wieder hier und lexika lizenzen habe ich
überhaupt auch nur einen flirt
disconnect leute ich weiß nicht ich nach
hause komme schreibt man dass man
einfach in die kommentare und dann sehen
wir von abend eventuell im livestream
dina und dann wenn ich da am live ein
bisschen gucken wo ich da lang muss wenn
es denn klappt mit dem livestream
ich kann natürlich nicht versprechen
klink ist treffpunkt ev / von craft da
steht auch immer in der beschreibung
können worauf abonnieren klicken wenn
ihr wollt wenn nicht dann auch nicht und
dann weggefahren hat hält mich definitiv
über eine positive bewertung freuen wenn
nicht gefallen dann enorm runter und
dann tschüss